[Music]
hello welcome from central London we're
just a stone's throw away from the
houses of parliament in Westminster
we're here in central hall for this
intelligence squared debate on the
catholic church is a force for good in
the world well that's a subject that's
going to generate a lot of heat I think
and some light too I hope
I'm delighted to be chair of this debate
we have a panel which includes some of
the most provocative intelligent and
stimulating commentators and
practitioners on the subject arguing for
the motion the Archbishop of Abuja in
Nigeria John or Nikon the British
Conservative MP and Widdecombe arguing
against the motion the actor broadcaster
and author Stephen Fry and the
journalist and commentator Christopher
Hitchens well our first speaker is John
an icon whose grace the Archbishop of
Abuja the capital of Nigeria and His
grace is one of Africa's best-known most
respected commentators of the church the
Catholic Church so please make your way
to the podium speak at the microphone
friends I must I certainly must say I'm
grateful to be here
because is for me is more than a matter
of debate because that's what my life is
all about if I didn't believe that the
catholic church is a force for good
I would not devote my whole life to
precisely working in that institution
hoping that I am involved in something
that is good for the whole world you say
for me it'll be a Catholic is a gift of
God let me start with the word church
the Catholic Church obviously it means
many things to many people
but I think as an archbishop I should be
in a position to see what it does mean
especially to us Catholics yes the
Catholic churches is an institution and
some people say it is perhaps the best
organized institution in the world but
that's not really the essence of our
church we should go beyond institution
and for us the church is first and
foremost a community of believers and
this is a community of believers that is
spread all over the world made up of all
kinds of people and the institution
itself as well as those whom we cannot
Mali consider church people people
dressed up like me for example we are
there only because of that huge
community of people who claim who are
Catholics I'm stressing this so that
when you are asking yourself is a
Catholic Church a force for good in the
world that look at me that look at
Braddock this extent look at the
Catholics all over the world that the
church is a force for good in the world
seems obviously to me is quite obvious
the question probably we should ask is
what kind of force there was was an
arrogant dictator who asked in disdain
how many battalions has the poop
obviously he completely missed the point
it's not about military force of
physical force but it is about force
it's about the force of a spiritual
message the force of values which has
stood the test of 2,000 years and
only 2,000 years in time but has spread
its message all over the world
among different different kinds of
people different races we must also not
forget the sheer weight of the number of
Catholics I have checked the statistics
and we are told that now we have our 1.2
billion Catholics all over the world out
of a population of 6.6 billion 7.3
percent and these are young disa made up
of all categories of people young and
old women and men present farmers and
high tech professionals simple citizens
and even heads of states and world
leaders this is the great army that is a
great force for good in the world and
whatever they are doing we consider it
as being done largely also as a result
of the spirit that guides them
independent statistics have shown that
the Catholic Church is doing far more
than its numbers and its population
would probably suggest the action of the
church is most significant in
communities that are reduced to poverty
and misery by human neglect and
sometimes by hostile environments
talking of statistics I spoke recently
with the director-general of units which
is United Nations agency for HIV and
AIDS and he said that 26% of the health
institutions in the world directly
involved with the treatment of HIV and
AIDS are run by the Catholic Church and
please note that it is a well known
policy of our church that whenever we
are engaged in social welfare work it is
always given to all with us without any
discrimination whether you believe or
not irrespective of Crete indeed it is
an integral part of our faith that our
church is made up of sins and sinners we
are all struggling towards that
perfection which Jesus asked us to to
first follow nor am i denying that the
Catholic Church has always and
everywhere being good done excellent
things even sometimes in high levels but
this again only proves that we are in
this world even the late Pope John Paul
the second was had no difficulty at all
in admitting the the mistakes that
people who claim to be judged to be
catalysts and working in the name of the
church have done in the past and even
apologized and such gestures of apology
is very rare in our world today let me
conclude by by drawing attention to one
particular aspect of my faith which I
admire greatly my we are very open to
Dylan and moving and collaborating with
others and I think this is very
important for the world of our days we
are talking of the world of today we
need more and more efforts to link hands
across all divides so that we can manage
to make our planet a better please a
world of justice and peace
is there still anybody here who still
doubts whether the catholic church is a
force for good in the world thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]
our next speaker is Christopher Hitchens
he's arguing against the motion he is a
writer journalist and commentator
particularly well known for his
trenchant and views and very original
thinking so Christopher Hitchens let us
hear what you have to say your time
starts now please make your way to the
podium
I'm sorry to have to begin by
disagreeing with his grace if you're
going to be a serious grown-up person
and appear to defend the Catholic Church
in public in front of an educated and
literate audience you simply have to
start by making a great number of
heartfelt apologies and requests for
contrition and forgiveness now you might
ask you're fully entitled to ask
brothers and sisters Who am I to say
that well in the jubilee millennium year
of 2000 the Vatican spokesman Bishop
Piero Marini said explaining the whole
sermon of apology given by His Holiness
the Pope given the number of sins we've
committed in the course of twenty
centuries reference to them must
necessarily be rather summary when I
think Bishop Marini had met just about
right I'll have to be summary to his
holiness on that occasion it was March
the 12th 2000 if you wish to look it up
beg forgiveness for among some other
things the Crusades the Inquisition the
persecution of a Jewish people injustice
towards women that's half the human race
right there and the forced conversion of
indigenous peoples especially in South
America the African slave trade the
admission that Galileo was right
and for silence during Hitler's Final
Solution or Shoah and it doesn't end
there they're a smaller but significant
equally significant of ours of a very
bad conscience these have included
regret for the rape and the torture of
orphans and other children in church run
schools in almost every country on earth
from Ireland to Australia these are very
serious matters and they're not to be
laughed off by references to the
occasional work of Catholic Charities
but I draw your attention not just to
the apologists ladies and gentlemen but
to the evasive and euphemistic form that
they take Joseph Ratzinger the current
pope considered by some by Catholics to
The Vicar of Christ on earth in his
comment one of the few he's made on the
institutionalization of rape and torture
and maltreatment of children in Catholic
institutions he said it's a very severe
crisis which which involves us he said
in the following in the need for
applying to these victims the most
loving pastoral care where I'm sorry
they've already had that
and to say that this is the
responsibility laid upon you by the the
horrific admission that you've already
had to make is not accepting
responsibility in any adult sense the
same euphemism comes in the term some
Christians allowed themselves to be
deceived in this way and to act against
the gospel well anti-semitism was
preached as an official doctrine of the
church until 1964 do you think that
might have something to do with public
opinion in Austria and Bavaria and
Poland and Lithuania
they'll come a time when the church will
issue apologies and explanations and
half-baked Appeals for forgiveness for
things it's still doing I think that
there will be an apology for what
happened in Rwanda the most catholic
country in africa where priests and nuns
and bishops are on trial for inciting
from their pulpits and on the church's
radio stations and newspapers the
massacre of their brothers and sisters
staying in africa i think it will one
day be admitted with shame that it might
have been in error to say that aids is
bad as a disease very bad but not quite
as bad as condoms are bad or not as
immoral in the same way
I said if the presence of His grace and
I say it to his face the preachings of
his church are responsible for the death
and suffering and misery of millions of
his brother and sister Africans and he
should apologize for it he should show
some can shame
for condemning my friend Stephen Fry for
his nature for say for saying you
couldn't be a member of our church
you're born and said
[Applause]
he's not been condemned for what he does
he's being condemned for what he is
you're a child are made in the image of
God oh no you're not you're a [ __ ] and
you can't join your church and you can't
go to heaven this is disgraceful
it's inhuman it's obscene and it comes
from a clutch of hysterical sinister
virgins who've already betrayed their
charge in the children of their own
church for shame for shame
I don't wish any ill on any fellow
primate or mammal of mine so I'm not I
don't at all look forward to the death
of fur
though Joseph Ratzinger James or any
other person already except for one tiny
reason which I want to confess and share
with you when he dies there's quite a
long interval till the Conclave can meet
and for that whole time that whole
interval it's a delicious lucid
interviewed there isn't anyone on earth
who claims to be infallible isn't that
nice
all I think all I wanna propose in
closing is this that if the human
species is to rise to the full height
that's demanded by its dignity and by
its intelligence we must all of us move
to a state of affairs where that
condition is permanent and I think we
should get on with it
okay thank you for having me
[Applause]
[Music]
well Christopher thank you very much for
all that our next speaker is going to
have her work cut out because she's
speaking in favor of the motion that the
Catholic Church is a force for good the
Conservative MP and former government
minister and Widdecombe she's as well
known for her religious views as for her
politics if you recall she left the
Church of England in 1992 in a blaze of
publicity when it allowed the ordination
of women priests the following year she
converted to Catholicism and has become
one of the most vocal and staunchest
defenders of the Catholic Church since
then and Widdecombe the floor is yours
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
if apology is a do tonight they are do
from Christopher Hitchens who has just
run through one of the longest series of
misrepresentations of the Catholic
Church that I have heard in a long time
he has said with that certainty which
characterizes these utterances that the
Catholic Church has had a history of
anti-semitism let us just look at the
record of the Catholic Church when the
Jewish community was under the most
serious threat that it has faced in
recent centuries and just look at the
role that the Catholic Church played in
the last World War mr. Hitchens
ignores the thousands of Jews who were
secreted and rescued in churches and
monasteries throughout Europe he ignores
the 3,000 Jews who in the course of that
conflict took refuge in the Pope's
own summer palace and coming nearer to
our day of course Christopher Hitchens
is right and who could possibly dispute
with him that the abuse of children of
innocent children is one in fact it is
the worst offense that anybody can
commit of that no doubt but again he
seems to think that the Catholic Church
should have had some unique insight
which demonstrably was lacking in
society as a whole do not expect the
Catholic Church somehow when that was
the state of knowledge at the time to
have acted in a unique and completely
different way and
respect yes of course in retrospect yup
in retrospect it should have done so
should the magistrates show should so
should the Samaritans so should the
National Council of civil liberties but
when we ask who whether the catholic
church is a force for good let's just
try to imagine a world today without for
example the billions of pans that are
poured into overseas aid by the catholic
church contributing year-on-year more
than any single nation imagine the
developing world had been left without
the input of the medicine and the
education that was brought to it by the
missions imagine the absence of those
collection sunday upon sunday for famine
relief imagine the absence of the church
in the local community we play a vital
role and you don't need to be a catholic
to acknowledge that we play that role
what is the church it is its members it
is the nuns and the monks and the
priests and the lay workers and the
congregations it is not just the
hierarchy of the church and i believe
that the church to which I belong is a
massive massive force for good but there
does not just keep the debate at that
level I knew somehow that when we were
here tonight we would be discussing
child abuse and condoms they came in the
end I was almost thought we were going
to get through an entire speech without
condoms and Christopher Hitchens but we
got them at the end but that that is not
what the Catholic Church is about it
isn't only about the physical relief of
the poor it isn't only a
the work it does on earth but it is the
message that it preaches and that
message is one of hope that message is
one of salvation and it is all very well
for some people in their intellectual
arrogance to say we didn't do it at that
but actually billions of people across
the world live by that message of hope
and of salvation they try to live by the
commandments and also by the
interpretation of those Commandments by
Christ yeah sometimes they fail
sometimes their leaders fail human
beings do fail but overwhelmingly I say
to you tonight with no apology or ever
that a world without the Catholic Church
would be poor earth would be more
hopeless and would be a worse place in
which to live
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well thank you very much indeed Ann
Widdecombe and our final speaker is
against the motion Stephen Fry a bit of
an all-rounder really Stephen can turn
his hand to many things
Stephen let's hear your view see how
well you do in the popularity stakes
with people in the Vatican
[Applause]
[Applause]
I genuinely believe that the Catholic
Church is not to put it at its mildest a
force for good in the world and
therefore it is important for me to try
and marshal my facts as well I can to
explain why I think that but I want
first of all to say that I have no
quarrel no argument and I wish to
express no contempt for individual
devout and pious members of that church
it would be impertinent and wrong on me
to express any antagonism towards any
individual who wishes to find salvation
in whatever form they wish to express it
that to me is sacrosanct as much as any
article of faith is sacrosanct to anyone
of any church or any faith in the world
it's very important it's also very
important to me as it happens that I
have my own beliefs they are belief in
the Enlightenment their belief in the
eternal adventure of trying to discover
moral truth in the world and there is
nothing sadly that the Catholic Church
and it's higher works
likes to do more than to attack the
Enlightenment it did so at the time
reference was made to Galileo and the
fact that he was tortured for trying to
explain the Copernican theory of the
universe just imagine in this square
mile how many people were burned for
reading the Bible in English and one of
the principal burners and torturers of
those who tried to read the Bible in
English here in London was Thomas Moore
now that's a long time ago it's not
relevant except that it was only last
century that Thomas Moore was made a
saint and it was only in the year 2000
that the last Pope the pole he he made
it Thomas More the patron saint of
politicians this is a man who put people
on the rack for daring to own a Bible in
English he tortured them for owning a
Bible in their own language the idea
that the Catholic Church exists to
disseminate the word of the Lord is
nonsense it is the
the owner of the truth for the billions
that it likes to boast about because
those billions are uneducated and poor
as again it likes to boast about it's
perhaps unfair of me as a gay man to
moan that this enormous institution
which is the largest and most powerful
Church on earth has over a billion if
they like to tell us members each one of
whom is under strict instructions to
believe the dogmas of the church but may
wrestle with them personally of course
it's hard for me to be told that I'm
evil because I think of myself as
someone who is filled with love whose
only purpose in life was to achieve love
and who feels love for so much of nature
and the world and for everything else we
certainly don't need the stigmatization
the victimization that leads to the
playground bullying when people say
you're a disordered morally evil
individual that's not nice
it is nice
[Applause]
the kind of cruelty in Catholic
education the kind of child let's not
call it child abuse it was child rape
the kind of child rape that went on
systematically for so long let's imagine
that we can overlook this and say it is
nothing whatever to do with the
structure and nature of the Catholic
Church and the twisted neurotic and
hysterical way that its leaders are
chosen the celibacy the nuns the monks
the priesthood this is not natural and
normal ladies and gentlemen in 2009 it
really isn't
[Applause]
I have yet to approach one of the
subjects dearest to my heart I've made
three documentary films on the subject
of AIDS in Africa my particular love is
the country of Uganda it is one of the
countries I love most in the world there
was a period when Uganda had the worst
incidence of hiv/aids in the world but
through an amazing initiative called ABC
abstinence be faithful correct use of
condoms those three I'm not denying that
abstinence is a very good way of not
getting AIDS it really is it works so
does being faithful but so do condoms
and do not deny it
and this Pope this Pope not satisfied
not satisfied with saying condoms are
against our religion please consider
first abstinence second being faithful
to your partner he spreads the lie that
condoms actually increase the incidence
of AIDS he actually makes sure that Aid
is conditional on saying no to condoms I
have been to there's a hospital in the
Windy in the West of Uganda where I do
quite a lot of work it is unbelievable
the pain and suffering you see now yes
yes it is true abstinence will stop it
it's it's the strange thing about this
church it is obsessed with sex
absolutely obsessed now they will say
they will say we with our permissive
society and our rude jokes are obsessed
no we have a healthy attitude we like it
it's fun it's jolly because it's a
primary impulse it can be dangerous and
dark and difficult it's a bit like food
in that respect only even more exciting
the only people who are obsessed with
food are anorexic and the morbidly obese
and that in erotic terms is the Catholic
Church in a nutshell
[Applause]
[Applause]
do you know who would be the last person
ever to be accepted as the Prince of the
church the Galilean carpenter that Jew
they would pick him out before he tried
to cross the threshold he would be so
ill at ease in the church what would he
think what would he think of sin Peters
what would he think of the wealth and
the power and the self-justification and
the weeding apologies
[Applause]
the Pope could decide that all this
power all this wealth this hierarchy of
princes and bishops and Archbishop's and
priests and monks and nuns could be sent
out in the world with money and art
treasures to put the back in the
countries that they once raped and
violated they could give that money away
and they could concentrate on the
apparent essence of their belief and
then I would stand here and say the
Catholic Church may well be a force for
good in the world but until that day it
is not thank you
well Stephen Fry thank you very much so
you've heard all our four speakers it's
gonna be your turn the audience next and
I'll give you a couple of minutes to
think about what you want to ask our
panelists any questions or comments you
may wish to make because I'm going to
give you now the results of that vote
that you all gave when you were coming
in here to central hall the motion is
the catholic church is a force for good
in the world in favor of the motion were
678 against the motion that the catholic
church is a force for good was 1102 big
difference however three hundred and
forty six of you were undecided so
Archbishop and Ann Widdecombe you're
going to have to not over win over the
undecided but actually convert some from
the other side let's see if we can sway
any opinions here amongst all of you by
listening to some points that you wish
to raise with the panel and then we're
going to ask you to vote again now put
your hand up if you want to speak a
question the lady with the spectacles
here I would like to ask mr. Hutchins if
he is only against the Catholic Church
or against all religions okay go back
there lady in the pink hi there and this
is a question for Christopher Hitchens
many people today feel that we're really
living in some kind of moral crisis and
you can see that all around us now if
one thing the Catholic Church does do
for good in my opinion is give us the
Ten Commandments a very basic obvious
way of giving us some kind of moral
guidance would you not agree with that
the lady in front began by asking me do
I reserve this condemnation only for the
Holy Roman Church and not for other
Catholics for example I presume time
Catholics and Protestants and so on I
think they're all the same equivalent
glimpses of the identical untruth now of
the commandments the first two or three
are entirely about fearing the author of
the orders entirely about being
terrified of someone who you're enjoying
to love I don't know about you ladies
and gentlemen but the idea of compulsory
love has always struck me as a bit shady
especially if you're in you're ordered
to love someone who you absolutely must
fear so the first three are look out for
me and keep at least one day of my way
or be terrified full time and Widdecombe
10 commandments firm bedrock of moral
teaching I would afford it quite obvious
that the Ten Commandments set out a
blueprint for a moral and successful
society let us just look at some of them
honor thy father and thy mother think of
today's disrespect thou shalt not steal
thou shalt not kill thou shalt not
commit adultery and thou shalt not covet
tell that to the bankers with their
bonuses okay want to come in briefly on
this the Ten Commandments
I am the Bible but my father knew it
before he became a Christian all Africa
religious recognized those basic norms
of morality everybody knows that
[Music]
let's take some more questions from the
floor okay this is a very simple
question for Ann Widdecombe you might
think it may be a naive question if so
I'd be very happy to be educated why is
it wrong for a woman to become a priest
but perfectly acceptable for a woman
such as yourself to become an MP okay
[Applause]
[Music]
and raised the point regarding the
billions that are poured into Africa
I respect your faith I respect the
message you give but why to pass that
message on do you need the finery that
you wear do you need the palace of the
Vatican okay point mate I think we're
going to go here
Archbishop of which current Roman
Catholic policy are you most ashamed I
[Applause]
[Music]
don't know whether you are serious in
that question or you just want to
provoke because if it all our Catholic
policies and I just dreamt overnight by
the Pope or anybody if it is a Catholic
policy it is reasonable it is but it is
based on our traditions and scriptures
and there's none about which I'm ashamed
and the other question about and I don't
know what billions of that he says the
Vatican as the builders of this world I
think are not in the Vatican we know
where they are and they are not coming
to Africa on the contrary Africa has
been sucked dry by those people those
multinationals they are the ones who
should be bringing them our money back
to us yeah I think we are we are
targeted the wrong place I come from
Africa and the funds come from church
agencies for us are very important and
one specific question to you why not
women priests in the Catholic Church
well no the specific question was why is
it not
right for a woman to be a priest but it
is for a woman to be an MP that's a
specific question right
and I have to say to you I mean that
really does betray a vast ignorance a
member of parliament male or female does
not stand in Persona Christi at the
point of consecration but I don't
believe that it is any more possible for
a woman to represent Christ at the point
of consecration than for a man to be the
Virgin Mary okay thanks
lots of lots of hands up and I really do
want to go around everybody's step panel
if you could keep your responses to the
point as much as you can up there please
question to Stephen Fry I'm a gastly but
I like you a lot about I don't know that
the catholic church condemns almost
sexuality as such only recommend
chastity for everybody I think
if I am not married I should be chaste
either I am homosexual or heterosexual
okay
all right thank you now hi question who
and where it commercially you accused
Christopher Hitchens of judging the
Catholic Church by the standards of the
time but surely the truths in your
doctrines are either eternal or they're
not
[Applause]
Stephen Fry the question about the
Catholic Church doesn't condemn
homosexuality that question asked it
simply does it does condemn it yes it
calls it the official word is disorder
but it was refined by the current
pontiff Ratzinger who called it a moral
evil but on the other hand we must
remember as the point that was made is
that the church is very loose on moral
evils because although they try to
accuse people like me and believe in me
empiricism and the Enlightenment of some
how what they call moral relativism as
if it's some appalling sin where what
actually means is thought they they for
example thought that slavery was
perfectly fine absolutely ok and then
they didn't and what is the point of the
Catholic Church of it says well we
couldn't know better because nobody else
did you just clarify for us on this
thing about homosexuality the Catholic
Church condemns the act but not the
individual did Jesus Christ himself
actually say anything about
homosexuality that is the wrong question
in this regard
no because no because we we are not
aware about homosexuality the morality
of homosexuality being a matter that
drew the attention of Jesus but Jesus
subtly spoke about about the ten
commandments and adultery and I do not
think we should deny the church the
rights to propound its own doctrines you
are not obliged to tip it that's amore
from the floor and then we'll come come
our life is based on the life of Jesus
Christ not on emotion or based on the
worldly the way the world is going so I
thank all the people who are listening
and they I think the message we are
getting here we need us to live a good
life okay thanks let's get to some more
comments okay we are perfectly clean
I spent 38 years of my life is to
Catholic and then I saw the light and my
life now is going back and forth to
Africa and next month I go to Uganda and
I'm working on trying to stop mother's
dying in pregnancy and childbirth what
I'm saying is please please reverse the
rule on condoms and Family Planning and
contraception and save lives
[Applause]
[Applause]
let's keep us moving briefly please as a
Catholic I'm actually very pleased to be
here this evening to hear two sides of a
very important argument and the positive
thing I take aways the Catholic Church
can take the opportunity to reflect upon
these comments and that we look for the
future and it's by actually accepting
these comments and by looking for a way
forward that the church can actually
grow and have a more important part of
the world alright thank you and what I
propose is this you've heard the points
that are raised some of them are
comments some of them were questions
you're going to have a few minutes to
make your closing statements please
incorporate these questions that you
heard in your closing statements because
audience I want you to vote again now
for those of you who are watching at
home if you'd like a brief in brooklet
on some of those issues that you've
heard raised today then please go to WWE
and you can download that booklet
anybody can do it in it's absolutely
free okay so everybody's doing that so
while you're all doing that it's gonna
take a little bit of time we're going to
hear the closing statements
incorporating some of the points that
you the audience raised and we're going
to do it in reverse order this time and
it's it's going to be Stephen Fry first
well it's been a really interesting
debate and I've got some of the
questions from the floor and I suppose
I'm slightly disappointed that and
waiting in particular should say oh I
knew they'd bring up condoms and child
rape and Thomas Xu ality it's a bit like
a burglar in court so you would bring up
that burglary and that
you never mentioned the fact I'd give my
father a birthday present yes yes are
you getting the message there is a
reason we hammer home these issues
because they matter there's such an
opportunity
owning a billion souls at baptism it's
such an opportunity to do something
remarkable to make this planet better
and it's an opportunity that is
constantly and arrogantly being avoided
and I'm sorry for that final statements
from Conservative MP and Widdecombe for
the motion that the Catholic Church is
our force for good in the world right we
have heard all the usual stuff about how
the Catholic Church being against
condoms has apparently caused untold
misery as I've said our opponents always
try to home in on sex when the teachings
of the church which are after all only
about the stability of family the
maintenance of fidelity the virtue of
chastity when the church teaches that as
one part of all it's teaching I do
sometimes despair at the way that these
debates always always come back to that
so I'm very pleased to have been here
tonight despite the fact that I think
the incoming poll was slightly
discouraging I'm very pleased to have
been here to have been here with the
archbishop and with the two gentlemen
opposite and thank you for the
opportunity
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
against the motion unanswered questions
amazing
no wonder where they asked repeatedly
would say whether they thought Stephen
Fry my friend was in a state of mortal
sin or not they wouldn't tell you
something about the question brought out
there in a coward well I say that
homosexuality is not just a form of sex
it's a form of love when it deserves our
respect for that reason that if when I
when my children were young
I'd have been proud to have Stephen as
their babysitter and I told them they
were lucky and if anyone came to my door
as a babysitter wearing hurry orders I'd
call first a cab and then the police
final statement from our final speaker
Archbishop of Abuja John Ania Kane
you've got to make your final pitch now
to the audience thank you very much I
just want to draw the attention of the
audience back to the topic and the topic
is quite clear the catholic church is a
force for good in the world
it did not say it is the only source for
good it is not say it has always been a
source for good is not in the past
nurses in the present tense is a source
for good I can I still have not seen how
they have in any way shown that the
Catholic Church is not a force for good
in the world I can say all kinds of
things about other people but I think it
is fair enough that then when it comes
to what does the church say about
condoms what they say about
homosexuality what does we say about
women please we need to take the trouble
to find find out exactly what it is say
not what the newspapers are saying that
we are saying we never said that the
Catholic Church is perfect we'll
continue to do our best to be as close
as we can to Jesus Christ and his what
he wants us to be and to constantly be a
force for good in the world and I thank
you
[Applause]
audience you've all voted again now the
moment of truth panel let me remind
everybody that before the debate when
everybody came in this is how you voted
for the motion that the Catholic Church
is a force for good in the world 678
against the motion 1102 and the
undecideds the do't knows were 346 this
is how you voted subsequently for the
motion that the catholic church is a
force for good from 678 it's gone to 268
[Applause]
i'm sorry
against the motion it's now 1876
and you can see that doesn't leave very
many don't knows it's 34 undecided so
commiserations Archbishop and Anglican
congratulations Stephen frying
Christopher Hitchens thank you for me
Zeynep Atari good bye
[Applause]
[Music]